A couple updates it,
I thought you might be interested in a US District Court in San Juan,
uh,
just dismissed the case of 7,000,
via Kenzie who had,
uh,
filed a suit against the federal government,
the,
uh,
department of the Navy,
seeking compensation for damages to their island,
uh,
and their health.
So that,
uh,
the suit has been in the making for about seven years.
And,
uh,
it will be appealed.
A,
also the Evelyn Case that,
uh,
you may have read about in green intelligence,
the two young children that,
uh,
claimed exposure to pesticides,
at a very young age,
uh,
that is going to trial in August now.
It was just announced,
uh,
after 10 years.
Uh,
so this should give you a pause to think about the,
uh,
effect.
Uh,
and costs of litigation in terms of Tosca reform.
Tosca reform was just introduced into both the house and the Senate and the
Senate by a Senator Lautenberg and the house by a Henry Waxman,
a and a for the first time in nearly 25 years.
There's some anticipation that there will be serious reform of the way that
commercial chemicals are regulated in the country.
Uh,
chemical company,
chemical companies,
curiously,
are motivated to see changes in this law because if products that they make in
this country,
you're not tested to the same standard as products,
a product testing requirements in Europe than us,
chemicals will not be allowed to be sold in Europe.
So the chemical companies are,
are extremely concerned about,
uh,
the idea of harmonizing law,
between the u s uh,
in the European Union.
Cape Wind,
uh,
is not been decided.
Uh,
but,
uh,
they're really appears to be no clear direction on the,
on the part of Ken Salazar at this point.
Should,
uh,
keep your eyes open for that.
Over the next week or so in a diesel update,
we talked about diesel exhaust and,
and we talked about the health consequences of particulate matter,
but,
uh,
there was new evidence that was released quite recently,
by,
uh,
needing Unger,
who is going to be a new assistant professor here next year and who has worked
with,
uh,
the,
Columbia University.
And,
uh,
NASA,
on the effect of particles.
And it's kind of a curious effect,
uh,
that,
particles of one form,
especially those that,
uh,
are attached to organic matter tend to have a reflective of effect to radiation.
So it basically,
uh,
may have a cooling effect,
whereas black carbon itself,
uh,
tends to absorb the radiation which would have a warming effect.
So it's interesting.
Diesel exhaust has been,
uh,
fingered as,
as,
uh,
identified as one of the,
the,
uh,
key sources of black carbon in the atmosphere that we need to pay much more
attention to a four.
It's warming effect on climate happy Earth Day,
40 years ago today,
a Earth Day,
uh,
occurred and,
your parents and,
uh,
and I probably remember it pretty well.
I was in Philadelphia at the time.
And,
uh,
it was a really a,
an interesting and,
and a highly confused time,
uh,
to be a college student.
And what was interesting about it to is it was a period of collision,
uh,
between,
different,
uh,
social movements that,
that really had a core base in universities.
And the,
uh,
the,
the collision was among the,
the anti war movement,
the civil rights movement as well as the environmental movement.
Nobody really knew what that meant at the time.
But,
uh,
you know,
sitting in Philadelphia and living in Philadelphia,
watching the yellow sunsets that,
uh,
occurred every evening,
because of the,
the filthy air and a rowing on the school kill river with the,
uh,
the crew team,
having to scrape the globules of a slime and material chemical waste that were
deposited legally into the school kill river,
uh,
really was,
an unhappy experience.
So it really,
it was also the dawn of,
of,
uh,
the modern era of environmental law in the nation.
And,
uh,
the clean air act,
a revisions,
the clean water act revisions,
uh,
the 1970s were really a time when a great energy was put into the,
the,
uh,
design of,
of environmental law.
And there was,
there was great expectation on the part of,
of,
uh,
people that,
had had worked in these movements to that,
uh,
that,
environmental quality would,
would change quite radically.
So I wanted to reflect with you today,
uh,
about,
you know,
imagining a,
an ideal society.
Uh,
we,
we think that we're facing many very severe problems,
but,
uh,
and that,
one of the themes of this course has been to try to help you judge the
effectiveness and potential of environmental law to shape behavior so that
people will behave more responsibly toward the environment and protect human
health and protect a,
a scarce,
natural resources.
So for,
for a moment,
I'd like you to kind of step back away from your perception of,
of all the problems that we face and,
uh,
instead,
to have you imagine an ideal society.
Uh,
so what would it look like?
Well,
you know,
environmental law really targets itself toward damages.
So knowledge is really a critical element of it and the knowledge that's
necessary in order for it to be effective as is quite complex.
So in the ideal world,
you would want to have perfect knowledge of externalities,
perfect predictive capacity.
What's the effect of my behavior going to be?
You'd want to have an efficient system for compensation,
for damages,
because all damages could never be avoided.
You'd also want to have a literate public,
uh,
public that was capable of understanding the technical information at a level of
detail that would make them potentially effective participants in decision
making.
Uh,
so literacy,
uh,
the capacity to learn is a really important component of this.
Uh,
you would want to have governmental authority and the resources,
uh,
to regulate.
So not only the,
uh,
the right to regulate that would be authorized by a congress or a parliament,
but also the resources to regulate.
And,
and those don't normally go hand in hand so that you often get the passage of a
law,
but you don't get the allocation of resources.
So there's the,
uh,
authorization a of money that's necessary.
Then there's the appropriation of money that's necessary.
And then EPA or whoever the agency is,
have to actually expend the money in order to,
uh,
have an effective response.
In an ideal society.
I'd say also that we need to pay.
We would be paying attention to the most vulnerable.
Uh,
they would be identified.
and they would be protected by statute.
Uh,
there would be equal protection for all.
And I'll talk more about to inequality and environmental law in a few moments.
And we would have figured out how to manage natural resources such as our
forests,
our soils are wildlife,
uh,
in,
in a sustainable way.
Uh,
and it's quite interesting when we use the word sustainability.
Um,
I,
I tend to cringe.
It's not my favorite word.
I think it's ambiguous and I think it is,
uh,
used way too loosely.
Uh,
but we're,
it seems to be clearest and have provided a model for effective law has been
with respect to managing resources such as forced,
uh,
fisheries where you can monitor a population,
you can monitor its rate of growth,
it's reproductive success.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
thinking about,
sustainable management of natural resources has been,
uh,
in,
in some instances a success story.
We,
I think I would imagine a stable climate as well.
So I want it to have you think with me also about what's been successful.
What can we point to as success stories.
And I think that a number of the cases,
I chose the cases quite deliberately,
uh,
for this course and a number of them demonstrate the potential of law,
to control behavior to achieve some of these objectives.
But I think clearly the,
uh,
the wilderness protection system and the national park system that we have in
the United States really is the envy of many nations in the world,
so that we have effectively set aside lands and we've offered,
uh,
we've restricted,
human access and,
and,
uh,
certain behaviors and extraction rights in these areas.
And,
and that really has been quite a bit of a successful policy.
Uh,
our national seashores I think represent a,
a really far approach,
uh,
that,
we're meant to provide recreational opportunities in the coastal zone.
Uh,
but as,
as I mentioned in the lecture on,
uh,
looking at Cape Cod and fire island and Padre Island and in point raise,
the fact that the government went into those areas and bought them or
consolidated federal ownership is going to restrict future development in a way,
uh,
that will reduce longterm costs associated with sea level rise and,
increased storm damage.
Uh,
the Adirondack park strikes me as also being a real success story in,
in many ways.
For me,
it really represents a model for regulating privately and use,
uh,
in the vicinity of highly valuable public lands.
Uh,
and remember this park was set aside back in the 1870s.
So that the,
the Adirondack park agency concept was really,
uh,
designed initially to protect what they thought of as biological diversity,
ecological,
uh,
diversity as well as integrity.
Uh,
whatever that meant.
uh,
at the time back in 1972,
when the,
the park agency statute was passed,
but,
uh,
eh,
almost inadvertently,
they had designed and energy conservation plan that really was right.
Quite remarkable member,
this idea that,
that you,
you,
uh,
regulate,
in demand,
very large lot sizes in the remote areas.
And then you basically take away the density requirements in the,
in the towns and villages.
They're really no,
uh,
urban centers in the Adirondacks,
but,
uh,
this open space preservation and incentive to increase density in the existing
areas that a already are developed and have infrastructure,
have roads,
have electric lines,
etc. It really is remarkable.
So in terms of an energy conservation strategy strategy,
uh,
that one might embed into a,
a land use plan,
it really was very innovative.
Uh,
they also use the idea of transferable development rights in the Adirondacks.
That,
uh,
I think is a very cool idea.
And there's a parallel here to,
uh,
the idea of,
of uh,
uh,
setting up these ecosystem service banks.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
I wanted to give you the example of,
a windmill.
We talked about to wind energy the other day,
or to give you the,
uh,
the idea that,
you know,
supposing you had property next to a windmill and you thought that you were
being a adversely effected by that,
uh,
is there a way that you might be,
compensated,
uh,
that would prevent you from litigating?
That might,
you might make you more accepting of the windmill LSL you know,
imagine that,
uh,
you,
you set up up a,
uh,
a square around a windmill or a,
a wind turbine and you basically use a,
uh,
the,
the thousand foot,
uh,
or the 300 meter distance from any property boundary that's been recommended,
to,
uh,
you know,
due to adverse effects.
So that,
that would constitute roughly about a hundred acres was supposing you had a
patch of people that lived,
uh,
adjacent to that land,
what could you do for them?
Uh,
that might make them more accepting of it.
But one thing you could do would be to provide them with development rights.
Uh,
but maybe they didn't want it.
They may not want to develop on their own property,
uh,
so that you could set up a bank,
whereby they could deposit these development rights in that bank and then
somebody who lived in a receiving zone or purchased property and in receiving
zone,
uh,
the receiving zone designed to increase density,
say in one of these urban centers that we,
I just mentioned then the developer that a one or to increase the density,
uh,
of,
of land that he owned or would buy in that urban zone would go to the bank and
purchase the credit so that the adjacent landowner to the turbine would be
compensated and development would be encouraged to,
to,
uh,
to grow near existing infrastructure.
So the ecosystem service banks that have grown up,
uh,
associated with wetlands,
a deg degradation,
also with a stream mitigation banking,
they present,
I think a,
uh,
a real model for us to follow in the future.
Uh,
the [inaudible] cap and trade program was clearly a success in reducing sulfur
dioxide and acid precipitation and a variety of other cases that we went through
in the course.
I think also demonstrate the potential effectiveness of law.
The nuclear weapons testing ban back in 1963 a population control.
Uh,
if,
if this were Earth Day back in 1970,
uh,
I remember,
the,
the lectures on Earth Day back in 1970 and they were about population control.
Uh,
population was thought to be the,
uh,
the source of,
environmental degradation.
Uh,
particularly in the developing world.
And population control efforts have been really quite successful.
We haven't,
uh,
we haven't discussed population control.
And I'm actually a little embarrassed to be a running an environmental studies
major without a,
a,
uh,
a demography element to it.
Uh,
but,
uh,
it really is a very important,
aspect of,
of environmental degradation in,
in terms of,
and I'm a,
as a father of children,
uh,
I could think of myself as a,
you know,
having,
uh,
created with my wife,
a beautiful young children.
Uh,
I could also think of it as creating future consumers,
uh,
that are going to be spending millions of dollars buying goods and services and
the developing land,
uh,
and,
doing whatever,
uh,
that,
would have an adverse effect on the environment.
So that a,
the mantra back in 1970 was population control is the primary approach that we
should be taking to,
to control environmental damage.
Uh,
the success in pesticides associated with a chlorinated heart,
hydrocarbons,
DDT,
Alderman,
dieldrin chemicals that would bio accumulate.
We really learned the bioaccumulation story predominantly from,
from a strontium 90,
uh,
back in,
in,
uh,
the weapons testing year.
Uh,
but then it was repeated in the 1960s in 1970 and these compounds were
successfully phased out.
It was one of the first objectives of William Ruckelshaus,
uh,
when he became the first administrator to the environmental protection agency.
Uh,
and you can see in the graphs,
uh,
the steady decline and concentrations,
not just in,
in birds,
uh,
but in fish and other wildlife as well as in human tissues.
A great success story.
And that also was modeled in the history of lead and has led,
was taken out of gasoline,
is led,
was taken out of paint.
You can see the,
uh,
the concentrations declining and the nation's children,
in,
in other nations where we're led was removed.
Uh,
it's,
it's really,
uh,
a very striking success story.
A chlorinated fluorocarbons known to adversely affect the,
uh,
the stratospheric ozone layer.
Uh,
we'll remove from aerosols.
PCBs were removed from,
from,
uh,
transmission,
tower coolers and other electronics.
Uh,
they also had built up in,
in a bio accumulated in,
in a wildlife as well as human tissues.
Uh,
the,
uh,
prevention of use of,
of a Spanish as a building material.
Our tobacco regulations,
we have a,
one of the lower lowest adoption rates now that,
uh,
then has existed at any other point,
previous and the in the 20th century.
Uh,
and food safety,
uh,
you may think of food safety is kind of an odd topic.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
in low income parts of the world,
food safety,
is it,
is it a major source of illness?
Uh,
and even in this country or the estimate by the Centers for disease control of
the number of illnesses per year experienced by contaminated food,
he's 76 million.
That's an enormous issue.
It has to do with the availability of water and the control of,
of microbes and a,
the way that that food is handled and Washington stored,
uh,
as well as how it's cooked.
Uh,
the organic food movement,
uh,
has been successful.
Uh,
it's,
it's a,
as I mentioned earlier,
the most rapidly growing sector in the food industry,
uh,
and drinking water quality,
poor drinking water quality in low income parts of the world is a major killer.
Uh,
the World Health Organization estimates that,
uh,
well more than a million children die from contaminated water each year.
We also suffer much less from a respiratory infections.
So forgive me the,
as the computer
for some reason is running through each one very slowly.
Come on.
So in contrast to a wearable laws work well,
where is it not work?
Well,
I think fossil fuel policy,
uh,
has been disastrous.
Um,
especially the kinds of subsidies that we've allowed the industry to,
to receive.
And I mentioned that it's simply the,
uh,
the,
the absence of,
of investment in,
in public transit,
uh,
and the enormity of the public investment in a highway development in highway
maintenance.
Our renewable energy policy has also been a disaster.
And despite the,
uh,
the improvements in the increase in funding that's going into renewable energy,
it's nowhere near sufficient in order to increase the proportion of renewable
energy that is necessary to,
to deal with the,
the co two problem that we face.
Personal consumption,
uh,
individual consumption,
individual purchasing is going up,
uh,
as are the number of people in the country or at about a 310 million people were
projected to go to,
to 350,
and about,
uh,
the next,
40 years,
uh,
and perhaps a reach 400 million people in,
in the nation.
So you multiply,
uh,
consumption,
of,
uh,
each individual times,
that scale.
Uh,
you know,
that we're sitting in a nation now where we have roughly 250 million
automobiles.
Uh,
and we're likely to,
uh,
to see that rise quite substantially,
so that,
uh,
people have fled to the suburbs.
Now they can't sell the property in the suburbs,
even if they wanted to live in an urban area.
Uh,
because of the declining a land value,
uh,
parks and protected areas are not being created any longer.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
the rate of adoption of parks and protected areas,
even though I just claimed that they were a great success where they were
created,
uh,
the rate of establishing parks and protected areas has fallen off quite
dramatically.
Uh,
since that time.
the park services land acquisition acquisition efforts have declined.
A biological diversity loss is also increasing,
uh,
as a,
as a function of habitat loss as a function of chemical applications,
pesticide applications,
a marine species exploitation is,
is increasing the rate of extinction a is increasing in,
in the world's oceans driven in part by,
by changing water quality and the coastal zone,
but driven also by unregulated fishing.
Uh,
particularly beyond the 200 mile limit.
the indoor as opposed to a or the outdoor as opposed to indoor focus of the
environmental protection agency has been a serious problem.
If you gave me a sample of your blood,
of your urine,
of your hair,
and we went down to CDC and had it tested,
we would find a variety of chemicals,
uh,
that,
come from the built environment.
So that,
that,
uh,
the,
absence of attention to a,
where we spend our time,
which is indoors is important.
Uh,
there is a new study that was just released that a announced that,
uh,
the average amount of time spent by the nation's children outdoors is now 42
minutes per week.
The average amount of time that,
uh,
children now spend in front of electronic media is now 52 hours per week.
So that there's something to that statistic that,
uh,
is worth paying a lot of attention to.
I'm here because my dad took me hiking when I was a kid.
Uh,
he took me to parks.
we'd hang out by streams.
Uh,
he take me down to,
uh,
the beach.
Uh,
but,
uh,
this is,
an increasingly rare experience as people are spending more time indoors and
more time staring at a electronic equipment,
hazardous sites.
Uh,
we are adding the number of hazardous sites to the,
uh,
list maintained by the government and the federal government and state
governments,
uh,
every year so that we're not restoring more than we're adding a,
and this is a very serious problem and the lessons of,
of,
uh,
a VA case,
the,
uh,
the long amount of time that the enormous resources necessary to clean these
facilities up.
And you should think about that if once you,
uh,
in,
in five years and six years as you think about where you want to live,
where you're going to rent a house or an apartment,
you think about a,
where you want to buy a house or buy land,
you should pay a lot of attention to the land use history in these areas.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
you can be sure that that,
you're buying land that was not formally a disposal site.
Chemicals in commerce,
plastics in our bodies and product labeling a,
our product labeling is,
is uh,
uh,
really,
one of the weakest among the higher income nations,
uh,
in,
the world.
Another key issue that,
uh,
I'll talk about a little bit more in a minute is what I call narrative
advantage.
Uh,
and if you think of,
uh,
the,
the variety of,
of different,
uh,
sources of our confusion about what to buy,
how to behave,
uh,
you know,
what energy consumption is associated with a purchase of an apple as opposed to
a hamburger,
a,
as you think about how much we don't know.
Uh,
I think also about,
uh,
how much,
what we do know and how our impressions are created,
uh,
by the narrative advantage of the powerful than written narrative advantage of
the corporate corporations as well as government.
So that they are basically framing the issue about what's worth worrying about.
I wanted to also say that,
that,
uh,
we did not have a chance to,
to talk much about,
uh,
CO2 trading programs.
Uh,
but we have a very active in and a important one ongoing right here in,
in,
uh,
Connecticut as we're part of a,
a 10 state,
uh,
plan to reduce co two emissions from the power plants in this region.
Uh,
and this was adopted as law in,
uh,
nine of these states,
but not in New York.
And it's interesting that a one energy company,
the indeck energy company sued the state of New York for creating cap and trade
regulations with no statutory authority.
So it could New York,
uh,
establish a cap and trade regulations and impose it on the utilities and its
state,
uh,
without statutory authority.
So this case is still pending.
The other states have adopted this approach.
And uh,
so that for all the utilities are for the largest utilities,
uh,
that,
contributes CO2 in this region.
Uh,
there has been a ceiling that has been established and,
uh,
between now and 2000 was,
excuse me,
2012 the ceiling will be stable and then it will decline.
As total a amount of co two emitted,
uh,
that's allowable.
Uh,
we'll,
uh,
be reduced and they will have to retrofit,
they will have to fuel switch,
uh,
in order to figure out how they're gonna meet that ceiling.
It's a very important approach.
So if you think back on what are the key problems with our broad body of
environmental law?
Well,
it's fractured.
It's fractured by problem,
it's fractured by media,
by air,
water,
food,
consumer products.
And often these problems have evolved a case by case and a motivated political
action,
uh,
in individual states or motivated the legislators in those individual states to
approach Congress and suggest that,
you know,
this is a,
an example of a problem that exists in every state.
We should pass national law to address it,
but each law is set up very differently.
It was not set up based upon a certain set of overriding,
guiding principles,
uh,
such as exist in the European Union.
And I'm going to make a few comparisons in a few moments to European
environmental law.
Uh,
by contrast,
it's fractured by level of government.
So we have,
uh,
law that,
is established by local governments,
state governments,
and the federal government that is often incompatible.
Uh,
and it's extremely confusing for,
for those that want to develop,
such as,
uh,
the,
the wind turbine farm,
Cape Wind up in Massachusetts.
It's a classic example of,
of a regulatory confusion and,
uh,
the,
the litigation and,
and delay and cost,
uh,
that,
in,
uh,
that ensues.
Uh,
we have little surveillance at the scale that's relevant to the individual.
And something that we have not spoken about that's really important is that,
uh,
environmental monitoring responsibilities and surveillance responsibilities have
largely been delegated to those that are regulated over the past several decades
by the environmental protection agency.
So that's an interesting idea.
I mean,
if you are,
say,
uh,
the,
the maker of,
um,
uh,
benzene,
you are responsible to report your benzene emissions from your smokestacks,
uh,
to the environmental protection agency.
There's no one else that is independent that,
uh,
monitors,
or is there no,
uh,
monitoring equipment that reports directly to the environmental protection
agency.
So thinking about,
uh,
the,
the way that the surveillance system is set up is really critical to the long
term effectiveness of,
of environmental law.
The next point is the pace of regulation.
And I just,
uh,
I mentioned the pace of litigation a few moments ago.
Uh,
the pace of regulation,
uh,
is,
is often slower than,
than a litigation.
So that,
that,
uh,
you wouldn't want a system ideally to be responsive to new found evidence of
risk.
So supposing I found that,
uh,
you know,
chemical x,
uh,
in the food supply is exceptionally dangerous and people are highly exposed and
they've got in their tissues well,
uh,
following that discovery and following a consensus amongst scientists that that
is a significant threat.
It normally takes 10 to 15,
and I've seen 20 years with respect to pesticides before the government responds
and then changes the regulation to,
to lower the allowable use of the chemical or sets a different ceiling on it.
In this basically a la law has the effect then a providing a,
a false sense of security when you think,
oh my gosh,
we have three dozen statutes in place,
uh,
we must be reasonably well protected as a society.
Well,
I think after this course you will be more skeptical.
It's difficult and costly to measure effectiveness and uh,
when,
uh,
ineffectiveness is found,
agencies are not happy about that.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
that's why we have a government accountability office that commonly we'll,
we'll look at,
uh,
the,
behavior of agencies and whether or not,
uh,
the,
the statute is,
is achieving the,
the,
a congressionally mandated intent.
Our law system is highly specialized in the sciences,
uh,
and it often takes a scientific training,
at a graduate level in order to be able to debate about the appropriateness of
certain standards.
Uh,
similarly,
if you're arguing about,
uh,
the,
the effect of human development on an endangered species habitat,
it takes expertise in biology often at the graduate level too,
to get a seat at the table.
So,
so think about that.
If you're considering a future in environmental management of one sort or
another,
uh,
think about how you might shore up your technical capacity.
Uh,
it's highly centralized and decision making.
It's a really difficult,
in order to participate in decision making at the federal level of government,
there are action channels and there are uh,
groups of people that are well known to the regulators that,
uh,
play a disproportionate role in making choices that,
that have,
uh,
a much,
highly more highly distributed a effect.
So I'm not going to go through all these different kinds of decision standards,
uh,
but we've touched on a variety of different approaches to setting standards in
different laws.
Remember the federal insecticide fungicide and rodenticide rodenticide act at
the top here,
it was a risk benefit balancing law.
Uh,
think about the food,
drug and cosmetic act as it applies to drugs.
Oh,
that's a risk risk trade off law so that a doctor prescribes a drug to you
because the doctor thinks that,
uh,
although there may be a risk of a side effect,
that the benefit to you is better is,
is a higher,
it's more significant than the side effect.
Risk cost benefit analysis is another form that,
a form of a decision making.
The analysis that is often demanded in,
in environmental law,
risk ceilings,
acceptable acceptable risk levels.
Now that,
uh,
I've seen the acceptable risk levels for cancer causing agents in the
environment that vary between one excess cancer,
uh,
is allowable per thousand people exposed,
as opposed to a standard that would allow a California standard,
uh,
one excess risk in a million people exposed.
And,
uh,
I've,
I've seen,
uh,
other proposals for one in 10 million so that the idea of acceptable risk,
is,
is quite variable and that can have an enormous effect on the,
the allowable concentration of a,
of a compound out there in the environment.
Uh,
the sustainable yield definition,
there's the multiple use and sustainable yield act that applies to the u s
forest service.
And this is a really interesting idea as well,
but it's,
it's,
it's technical,
so that one would have to look at a national forest and figure out how much
timber it normally produces,
how much could be harvested,
uh,
and without adversely affecting,
the sustained yield at that level.
So being able to identify,
uh,
the sustained yield and develop an understanding of,
of how you go into an area and you get the timber out without depleting the soil
resources,
say of organic matter and water holding capacity.
That's a technical issue.
A density restrictions,
land use segregation,
a disclosure and transparency requirements,
certification requirements inside the food production act or the reasonable
certainty of no harm standard in the food quality protection act is the most
rigid,
uh,
health protective standard that we've gotten.
The United States.
It's as health protective as any statute,
uh,
also in the European Union and also technological feasibility.
So what's feasible now as opposed to a technology forcing a standards that would
demand that a industry say lower their a auto emissions down to a level that's
not possible now,
but you give them a ceiling and say that you've got five years to reach that,
that a reduced ceiling,
uh,
restricting false claims,
a benefit or demanding,
uh,
expression of risk.
So product labeling and then restoration standards that exist inside the
resource conservation and Recovery Act and a,
the superfund law,
so that there are different forms of standards,
a different decision making criteria and analysis across these laws.
Uh,
I wanted to compare for just a couple of minutes,
some key principles,
a loft.
So I just said that that US law has evolved in incrementally in a patchwork
quilt fashion,
uh,
with a variety of these different standards that were in the last slide.
How about European law?
Well,
European law evolved based upon a collection of,
uh,
principles,
principles that are not embedded in all of our laws.
So we have no law in our country that,
uh,
that basically forces the,
the,
uh,
statute to comply with principles such as exist in the EU law.
Uh,
one is a high level of protection,
uh,
is demanded but not the highest.
Uh,
and this would force,
uh,
the definition of what high means.
Uh,
and it has,
and it's produced litigation.
Uh,
the precautionary principle that despite uncertainty in the effect of,
of a timber harvesting on an endangered species habitat or of a chemical on
human health,
despite the uncertainty,
uh,
it is a better idea,
to be precautionary,
to set a standard that would be a protective,
and this is quite similar to another principal that they call the prevention
principle that a prevention is better than the cure.
Uh,
and they also have the source principle,
uh,
that a problem should be managed at its source,
rather than down the road.
So,
you know,
if you've got a,
a,
if you have a nasty,
a pesticide,
uh,
are you going to manage that pesticide by,
allowing farmers to use it and,
uh,
then going out and monitoring its presence in the water supply or in the foods
that you eat?
Uh,
that's,
that's managing at the downstream level as opposed to at the,
at the source.
So a nip it in the bud if it's a really dangerous chemical prohibited,
uh,
or don't allow it to be used under certain circumstances.
The polluter pays principle,
uh,
that,
dictates that a polluters are financially responsible for the pollution that
they emit from their smokestacks.
From there,
uh,
from there,
pipe,
there waterline just discharge points,
uh,
and that they are also responsible for damages and they're responsible for
coming up to solutions to the problem that,
uh,
that they're creating a and also that they are open to liability claims.
Uh,
and finally the safeguard principle,
uh,
that,
member states in the European Union,
uh,
have the authority to adopt tougher laws,
given,
uh,
their particular conditions.
Now,
when I say that,
um,
I know that these seem like they're kind of dry principles,
but when I see that,
uh,
the,
the bell that should be going off in your head is a bell about a preemption and
to how important it is to think carefully about when,
under what circumstance do you want to preempt a lower level of government,
say France,
from adopting a tougher level of regulation than the European Union?
Or when do you want to have California,
uh,
be given the authority to adopt tougher air quality regs as opposed to,
those that are established by EPA.
So the safeguard principle,
uh,
cuts across all European law,
that gives the member nations the authority to set standards that are tougher
than,
uh,
the unions want to talk just a couple minutes about a poverty,
and the environment.
And we haven't spent much time on that during the course.
Uh,
but,
uh,
the impoverished in the world generally face degraded environmental conditions
compared to the more wealthy.
Uh,
and these are often ignored by governments.
exposures to hazards are normally hire a,
the poorest are left to the most marginal lands.
It's kind of interesting to watch what happens in a town even in Connecticut,
uh,
when,
developers have built on all of the really nice lands.
And then you have the old town dump,
the landfill that nobody wanted to live near,
uh,
and,
remained undeveloped.
Uh,
but as the town's reached build out,
meaning that all the other lands had been developed to the zoning density limit,
uh,
then increasingly you see,
lower income people moving into those areas.
There was the,
uh,
the Bhopal India chemical release back in 1984 that,
killed tens of thousands of people and injured hundreds of thousands of others.
Uh,
those people had,
uh,
basically migrated,
next to the chemical company,
uh,
and,
and set up camps,
uh,
that,
made them immediately adjacent to the,
to the edge of the chemical company.
And,
uh,
that,
that history,
uh,
I encourage you to take a look at it.
Uh,
the,
the chemical release of a methyl isocyanate,
uh,
killed or injured people in a matter of several hours because they were so close
to the plant.
There was no,
there's no buffer zone to it.
So the,
the poor tend not to have,
uh,
access to capital.
They tend not to have insurance.
Uh,
they tend not to have the capacity to understand and to manage risk.
The way that the wealthy do a healthcare surveillance is something that they
cannot afford.
Uh,
and litigation is really an opportunity.
So as you think about,
uh,
the relationship between environmental problems and,
the,
uh,
fascination and the drive that,
our nation has to,
to grow,
uh,
to produce more,
to consume more,
uh,
to,
to become wealthier.
Uh,
I want you to think more carefully about this.
I want you to think about whether or not this fascination with growth,
uh,
of,
of a bigger is better,
uh,
really is something that we need to confront a more directly,
the ethical affects of pursuing more,
uh,
more wealth.
Uh,
uh,
really have a variety of,
of,
uh,
dimensions.
Uh,
so that,
uh,
as you think about your own behavior,
your own pattern of consumption,
if you think about,
uh,
whether or not you really need that next iPod,
the next iPhone or the next iPhone,
uh,
APP,
if you think about the kinds of foods you want to buy in the marketplace,
you can start thinking about these as ethical choices,
uh,
and about to how they may cause a distributional pattern of,
of costs and benefits out in ways that that may not be easily identified.
So as wealth increases,
uh,
the opposite argument might go,
so to the following,
a control over modes of production control over,
uh,
labor and providing a labor with certain rights that they might not have had.
So wealthier nations tend to have higher protective standards for Labor,
or they have higher standards for the control of materials.
There's another mode of production component of the motor production,
uh,
as well as regulations on the use of capital.
Uh,
and the wealthier nations in the world also have more control and accountability
that's demanded of government.
Uh,
they have a higher education,
a higher capacity to identify risk.
Uh,
and as wealth increases,
environmental controls regulations become more sophisticated,
uh,
as does the capacity to buy insurance,
access to healthcare and the capacities to select risks.
And I,
and,
uh,
avoid them.
So,
you know,
one idea,
uh,
thinking about,
whether or not there is a trickle down effect,
uh,
so as the world becomes wealthier,
as the high income nations become wealthier,
uh,
is it,
is,
is there going to be a trickle down effect or should we systematically think
about how we might redistribute wealth,
knowledge,
authority in a sense of a collective ethic?
Uh,
and will this be a,
uh,
a stairway to improve environmental quality and human health?
Uh,
I want it to just a mention to and emphasize,
uh,
this idea once more of,
of narrative advantage,
uh,
and,
how critical it is given the scale of money that's being put into advertising.
So a half a trillion dollars per year in the world going into advertising,
promoting products,
uh,
promoting,
economic growth and,
uh,
making claims about a product,
benefits and normally not fully disclosing what product risks or a product a
longterm,
uh,
damages might be.
Uh,
we talked,
uh,
on many occasions in the course about the idea of,
of ignorance as being an underlying source for environmental problems.
Uh,
so I don't mean ignorance in a demeaning way at all.
I mean,
it's simply the absence.
I don't mean it to,
to infer the absence of capacity.
I mean,
uh,
to,
in for the absence of knowledge or the incapacity to develop that knowledge.
Uh,
but for no,
no reason of a personal problem.
Personal incapacity.
So what are the underlying sources?
Well,
illiteracy is clearly one of them.
A secrecy is another.
Deception is another privacies and other language barriers.
Uh,
but,
uh,
I'm increasingly fascinated by the idea that,
that,
uh,
legal control of knowledge in the form of trade secrecy,
in classified information or really critical targets,
uh,
that we need to manage more effectively in order to create a literate society
that might be able to participate in markets as well as in government decision
making in ways that will lead us to a,
a,
a more health protective,
environmentally responsible future.
So secrecy has a,
a very insidious and negative effect and we've seen it in a variety of cases.
Uh,
it concentrates knowledge among those with authority and power.
It actually is a form of social control.
Uh,
so if I have knowledge and I kit withhold it for you because it,
it basically will prevent you from,
uh,
being able to compete with me.
Uh,
then,
uh,
that basically is a form of,
of,
uh,
its authority,
its power for me to be able to control you.
A secrecy inhibits public intelligence on,
it enhances the persuasive power of elites,
again,
providing narrative advantage throughout the course,
uh,
across all of these cases.
Uh,
I had mentioned the importance of looking at distributional effects and avoiding
what I call here,
the veil of averages.
If,
if you allow yourself to be convinced of arguments,
uh,
based upon,
statistical claims of,
of,
uh,
the effect on average is going to be x,
or even the benefits on average are going to be y,
uh,
then,
you should not do that.
You should think much more carefully and deeply about distributional patterns in
society.
How is risk distributed?
How are benefits distributed?
Uh,
is there an overlap among the risks and the benefits?
do we want to structure law in a way that encourages that to be transparent and
overlapped?
So I'm going to close here and I'm going to,
uh,
just take a,
a little bit of licensed,
and I apologize for this because you,
you may think of me as being a paternal,
but,
uh,
this class represents,
I believe,
uh,
a class where I've now taught a about 2,500 Yale students.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this,
this has given me a perspective on,
uh,
on,
success,
uh,
of my students as I watched them,
down the road,
uh,
what careers they take,
what,
uh,
how they come back.
And,
uh,
you know,
what recommendations,
uh,
but,
but also,
uh,
you know,
want to,
uh,
let me know that,
they're taking some ideas into their,
into their future.
Uh,
so,
you know,
what advice could I give you?
Well,
you know,
I would encourage you to think really carefully about what drives you morally.
Uh,
what,
what are your dominant moral values?
And A,
I've got kids your age,
uh,
and I say that to them.
Give me your top five dominant moral values,
uh,
and learn to,
understand,
uh,
how those values might guide your behaviors.
Uh,
and you know,
in my life,
I've often result,
I've often concluded that,
boy,
you know,
if I just listened to that inner voice,
a would told me,
uh,
that would have told me what the right thing to do,
was and it would have been a better decision.
So learn to,
uh,
learn to trust your instincts about what's really important in your life.
It's not just about getting Richard,
uh,
learn yourself and then teach others a year at one of the most prestigious and
one of the best educational institutions in the world.
Uh,
and it's just such an incredible privilege for you to be here.
but I think now about it,
uh,
the educational experience that you're getting.
Uh,
you know,
not,
not in my course,
but in better courses,
uh,
as,
as a privilege,
as something that,
that really,
you have an obligation to carry on,
to,
to expand,
uh,
the knowledge of other people.
Lead by example.
Don't just tell people what to do.
People see you,
uh,
being focused and disciplined and taking on the toughest and meanest,
nastiest,
and dirtiest jobs.
They're going to respect that and they're going to follow you.
So focus and discipline is really a key to success.
Uh,
I would encourage you to reduce your access to your,
you're a reliance on electronic media.
Uh,
I,
I see students walking down the road,
um,
you know,
holding their,
their,
uh,
cell phones in front of them.
Uh,
no conversations at all.
I mean,
uh,
the,
the value of conversation is,
is enormous compared to the value of communication via electronic media.
Uh,
body language,
uh,
understanding,
how emotion and rationality,
uh,
are,
are mixed up.
And in a language you don't get that from Twitter.
You don't get that from,
uh,
emailing people.
So I encourage you to think carefully about the amount of time that you spend
your life in that way.
I worry a lot about what's going to happen in future generations because of the
way that,
that your generation and those younger are spending their time,
uh,
not going out and not experiencing the wild,
not experiencing the natural.
I mean,
I can't imagine that people would have the passion to care about the wild and
the natural,
uh,
or the pure,
the chemical free,
uh,
if,
they had not experienced it themselves.
So,
uh,
and,
and that's the reason that I take my classes out to the Adirondacks are I've
taken them to,
uh,
Wyoming or to other places because,
they,
many people just don't,
don't have that experience.
They were not a lucky enough to have the experience.
I had one when I was a kid,
uh,
consume what you need,
think really carefully about what you need,
um,
and,
uh,
you know,
how much space do you need?
Uh,
you know,
my argument with Croon Hall,
how much cubic feet of space do you really need per person in coon hall?
Is I look up at that 40 foot high ceiling.
Yes,
it's grant architecturally,
it's a wonderful,
uh,
aesthetic experience.
Uh,
but in the new age of being concerned about energy consumption,
uh,
and,
renewables,
is that a luxury that we can really afford?
Uh,
no.
What you're consuming,
you know,
if anything,
you should walk away from this course,
uh,
being skeptical about this issue.
Uh,
it's hard to do what's in your environment.
you know,
what,
what do you need to protect yourself against a drive less?
Uh,
self propel yourself more.
It's uh,
not only good for the climate.
Uh,
it's great for your health.
And you remember the design of that Centers for Disease Control building a
specifically designed with that staircase that has,
is beautiful,
beautiful staircase with white glass panes going up the side of the stairwell
that encourages everybody to get to their office up on the seventh or eighth
floor by walking up the steps as opposed to to,
uh,
taking the elevator that's in the back of the building,
become politically active regardless of your party.
Uh,
show up.
It's really pretty remarkable.
And I,
you know,
I hesitate to say this in a class where,
I know a bunch of,
bunch of,
you have a,
uh,
not shown up all the time,
but a lot of successes is involved in the social relationships that you've
developed just by showing up and paying attention.
Uh,
you know,
I,
I have thought long and hard,
uh,
whether or not I wanted to adopt a Harvard law school's a prohibition of the use
of,
uh,
laptops in the classroom.
And I decided not to do that.
So I mean,
I,
it,
I figured that if I can't engage you a in a,
in a lecture and if I regulate your use of laptop and I also then I shouldn't,
I shouldn't regulate it.
But I also feel that that,
uh,
those of you that,
are not paying attention,
uh,
you know,
there,
there are probably some pretty good reasons for it.
Uh,
and the most important lesson I think I have for you is to be confident about
yourself.
And a,
I want you to think about this one,
uh,
really carefully,
because,
uh,
my belief is,
is really that
you wouldn't be here
at Yale if you did not have the capacity to change the world.
And you know,
how many yell leaders have had enormous influence in corporations,
in government,
in the nonprofit community.
Uh,
so that capacity is a,
it's an enormous gift.
And I'll leave you with one final reflection is that you may think it's really
hard to induce change in the world,
but it's not,
it's really not.
You know,
he demonstrate your passion,
you develop the knowledge,
uh,
you develop a coalition.
You can make change at any level of government.
So be confident about yourself and,
uh,
and,
go,
go in peace.
So thank you very much for a great term.
[inaudible].